hello everyone and welcome to not one
but two really awesome short bullet
games uh from uh yesterday's match
between daniel naradicki and magnus
carlsen uh some of you guys requested me
to show a few games and i thought maybe
well since they're bullet i'm just gonna
squeeze two of them in one video and
they are very short and they're very
enjoyable so usually uh when you're
preparing for a world chess championship
match you you know it's usually done in
secrecy no one knows what you're doing
but here magnus even though it's uh less
than a month until the world
championship match he enjoys a nice
bullet match online against um daniel
narodicki here so let's enjoy it and
then we're gonna discuss the uh result
of the match uh afterwards so yeah this
is the first game we're gonna show it
features the owens defense uh let's
check it out so now this key opens with
e4 and we have b6 by magnus so it's uh
going for this uh bishop b7 to uh to
grab that pawn on e4 right away a white
grabs the center as this is what you
should always do if black allows it
bishop to b7 and bishop to d3 now just
the defending the pawn here and magnus
goes for e6 here
for those of you who are new to the
channel i always liked you know maybe
once a year to show the the famous greco
miniature in this position uh where if
black goes immediately with f5 uh just
in case this happens to you you know
that you can capture this pawn it seems
like you can't because the g2 pawn is
hanging
but if the pawn is captured and black
captures on g2 just play queen h5 check
and that's it white is better regardless
of what black plays g6 is the only move
here and after f captures now you have
to play something like bishop to g7 but
still white is much much better here in
the actual game or rather the supposed
game knight to f6 was played greco's
opponent went for the queen and here
greco just captured on h7 opened up a
discovery the only move for black is to
capture the queen and now bishop to g6
ends in a very nice checkmate here so in
case you haven't seen that one that is
the the famous greco miniature but of
course magnus knows this he plays e6 uh
we have knight to c3 d6 and now f4
grabbing even more space in the center
as magnus allows it uh knight to d7 and
now uh knight to f3 preparing the castle
knight g2 f6 and here uh another disk
just castles with bishop to e7 and now
you could go for something like queen to
e1 going for g3 g7 uh this uh also is a
known idea but here another ski plays e5
and it is now as of move eight that we
have a completely new game so uh
carlson's knight here is attacked he
moves it to d5 and if this was a normal
game probably we would see something
like captures captures and c4 attacking
the bishop and if the bush moves back
maybe even f5 makes sense uh but this is
a bullet game uh so naruto goes for
queen to e1 now he wants to go uh queen
g3 put pressure here then at some point
maybe you can even play f5 the queen
will be attacking g7 maybe even bishop
to h6 will be an idea so that's what
he's going for so knight to b4 magnus
knows that this bishop is an extremely
strong piece so of course he threatens
it and the queen to g3 now going after
the g7 pawn and now if you cancel here
then you kind of run into what we've
discussed f5 uh threatening f6 and for
example if d captures an e5 uh d
captures an e5 knight captures on d3 uh
we can simply play bishop to h6 here
threatening uh mate and then black would
have a tough time getting out of this
[Music]
sorry about that had to really have to
get that one so here black would really
have a hard time dealing with this so
instead magnus just plays g6 right away
and uh we have f5 nonetheless so here f5
and it's a question how to react to this
of course you have to capture it but
what with uh if g captures then you
allow queen to g7 but even this might be
acceptable then rook to fate and black
plays this but in the actual game magnus
played e captures on f5 and now he
allows this bishop to be shifted over to
c4 attacking this f7 pawn and now uh
again very very dangerous stuff here uh
the the c2 pawn is being offered but if
knight captures on c2 then we go from
knight to g5 putting pressure uh on the
f
seven pawn and if castles here for
example even rook captures an f5 is an
idea these are all uh of course um uh uh
ideas that uh uh daniel is well aware of
and uh he uh
has uh has experience playing before
such position so it would be very
dangerous here the rook cannot be
accepted and black really has to figure
out how to play this probably d5 we have
to block this diagonal uh but of course
if this is captured in just this or even
better knight captures an f7 check picks
up the queen it just falls apart so
instead after bishop c4 magnus goes for
the immediate d5 we want to get rid of
that bishop from this diagonal bishop to
b3 and now c6 just strengthening the
position here and now you could go for
something like bishop to h6 right away
to prevent castles but we have a3 first
attacking the knight knight a6 and only
now
bishop to h6
preventing black from castling but also
it's a very very nice square for the
bishop uh and here knight to c7 the
problem is you could also play queen to
c7 maybe try and castle queen side for
example knight to e2 we want to free up
this um uh push for for the pawn and if
a castle's queen said we can just play
c4 and already it's white who's on the
attack looks very dangerous so instead
after bishop to h6 knight to c7 now
magnus wants to get some control over
the e6 square because you know this
knight is coming to g5 at some point and
that point is now so knight g5 and now
knight to f8 so gaining excellent
control over this e6 square and now how
do you continue here uh it's not um
all that easy to to figure out but you
could play something like knight seat
the e4 it seems like such a crazy move
to play because the pawn the knight can
be captured via the d-pawn or end via
the f-pawn
but again it's a bullet game you don't
have time to spot everything and now
it's very dangerous if this uh is
captured then bishop and knight uh uh
sorry about that arrow attack the f7
pawn and if this is captured then rook
and knight attacked the f7 pawn and it
becomes a very very dangerous probably
it can be captured but uh you know in
the actual game knights the e2 was
played and now this he wants to shift
the knight to f4 and then control e6 but
this allows magnus to consolidate a
little bit bishop to a6 now it prevents
the knight from moving and you maybe
even want to capture this knight because
the bishop here wasn't really doing all
that much uh but naruditsuki uh the
attacking player that he is just offers
up the
exchange sacrifice so knight f4 and
magnus captures it he says all right
let's see what you have bishop captures
on f1 and now uh the first surprise of
the game not rook captures an f1 but
actually rook to e1 and this is very
very interesting now uh this could uh
either be some sort of a a remarkable uh
idea that you know
if magnus plays something then he plays
something else or or it's a mouse slip
but either way it is very interesting uh
for example if magnus decides to save
his bishop and goes back bishop to a6
then maybe e6 and then
the attack really happens for example if
captures on e6 we're going to capture
here we're going to capture we're going
to capture and after captures and
captures you get this position where
it's uh you know black is of course
better he's up a piece but it's a bullet
game why why not play this you have a
very nice uh
rook on e6 the queen is very active uh
the the bishop fair is still uh in the
game so maybe this is what he was going
for another explanation is that maybe
it's just a mouse slip but okay either
way rook to e1 and magnus uh doesn't
care about his bishop he just
consolidates and plays the knight f e6
right away uh he won he does not want to
allow this pawn to e6 push uh and now we
have knight g captures on e6 knight
captures on e6 and only now rook
captures an f1 as there really is
nothing better
so here magnus grabs the d4 pawn knight
captures on d4 but this also means that
he allows this push pawn to e6 so here
we have queen to d6 not caring about
this capture e captures on f7 with czech
king captures on f7 and now he doesn't
want to
part with his light square bishop here
it's a very very very nice piece the
bishop fair is doing good work here so
he puts it to a2 but this also means
that it's well just very easy for magnus
to end the game on the spot so feel free
to pause the video here and win the game
for magnus
in the coolest way possible while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding any of the
winning ideas because most of them are
you're just you know up material so in
any move here really would allow you to
to still be winning the game but the
movie that we're looking for and that
most of you guys found if not all of you
is queen captures on f4 uh this is what
uh
magnus played and he was in this
position on move 24 that daniel nardiski
resigned in the game as there is nothing
more to be done here he's now down
simply too much material and the queen
cannot be accepted if the queen is
accepted then comes knight to e to check
with this beautiful fork here forking
the king the queen but also the bishop
and now after the king moves we can just
capture and after king captures the
attack is over uh
black is just up too much material as
you can see he's up two pawns and also
up the exchange so there's no point in
in playing this
so this is the first game and the second
one it's uh
a bit more complicated but also also
very enjoyable so again narudinski with
white magnus with the black we have e4
e5 by magnus knight to c3 d6 and now f4
so the vienna game the omaha gambit is
on the board uh now usually you want to
capture on f4 here but magnus first goes
for knight to f6 it's a very very
annoying variation that you really have
to know if you play this with white
knight to f3 e captures on f4 so now he
accepts it of course white plays d4 he
wants to recollect his pawn and not
knight the h5 uh similar ideas are also
seen in the king's gambit where black
tries to
uh
defend his gambite pawn but usually it
doesn't work all that well so let's see
how it works here so bishop to c4 uh
white uh usually doesn't care about the
pawn he wants to get some rapid
development in bishop to e7 we have
castles magnus castles and now uh there
is a game where knight to g5 uh was
played and it's possible because the
knight on h5 is undefended but here uh
we have e5 and it is now as of move
eight that we have a completely new game
uh so let's see how magnus deals with
this he plays knight to c6 uh put some
pressure on the pawn here e captures on
d6 and now one would expect bishop
captures her queen captures but no
magnus captures with the c pawn for some
reason probably taking away the e5
square from
from the knight here not allowing any
any such ideas uh but also it's it's
just very weird so here at knights the
d5 narudic once they eliminated this
strong bishop here uh bishop to e6 and
now knight captures an e7 and you can't
capture with the queen if you capture
with the queen d5 and black's in big
trouble so after knight captures on e7
we have knight captures by magnus and
now
we have bishop
back to d3 uh also possible here and
quite better is just captures on e6 and
after f captures knight g5 attacking the
the knight here and also the e6 pawn but
i have to remind everyone this is bullet
so of course everything can be seen even
here black has the annoying rook to f5
uh kind of saying that okay capture my
knight and if the knight is captured h6
here now the knight can't move because
the queen hangs but still it's very much
playable bishop captures h captures
we're gonna play bishop captures and
white of course retains uh a better
position here but okay uh bishop back
the d3 was played and now we have knight
to g6 so now all of a sudden magnus
doesn't have one knight guarding the df4
pawn but actually two knights so c3 uh
adding more defense to this d4 pawn here
and now rook to e8 so here white really
has to figure out how to get this uh
dark square bishop into the game so
bishop to d2 we have to start somewhere
and now bishop to g4 just spinning the
knight of course you never have to worry
about h3 because the
white king's position is already too too
much open queen to c2 now the knight
can't move because bishop can capture on
h7
and now queen to d7 connecting the rooks
and now the other rook can come into the
game as well we have rook 8 to e1 and
magnus very happily trades the rooks
rook captures rook captures and rook to
e8 he wants to trade another pair of
rocks so naruditsuki prevents this he
plays bishop to e4
but magnus says nope uh move that bishop
we are we are definitely trading rooks
here so bishop back to d3 and now why
not uh bishop captures an f3 we open up
the white king's position rook capture
78 with check first queen captures and g
captures on f3 so now uh this is the
position uh queen and two bishops
against queen and two knights and magnus
still has this annoying pawn here uh
that
he uh well uh managed to save uh for
from the beginning and it seems like
here you could actually remove uh uh the
defender but it's uh first black to move
so here black goes knight to h4 he
offers the pawn here for the f3 pawn so
narudicky defends it and now g5 and now
you're not capturing this pawn so it's a
really a remarkable story of how this
pawn survived for for such a long time
which also means if we manage to trade
down all of our pieces we're just in a
king and fun end game where black is up
a pawn also something that you have to
consider at all times when you play your
own games so queen to b3 putting
pressure on the b7 pawn but this just
allows magnus a really really powerful
move and that is queen to c6 attacking
and defending at the same time and how
do you defend this well bishop to e2 but
now now comes the moment of uh well
just reality feel free to pause the
video and try to find the absolute best
move for magnus here while i give you a
couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding this well
sacrifice that cannot be ignored and for
those who just want to enjoy the show it
is of course knight to g for check and
now the knight has to be captured if if
you just move the king then we capture
on f3 for free uh but uh regardless of
what you do you know you're not going to
have a great time so here f captures on
g4 was played now comes queen to g2 with
check king the e1 queen the g1 with
check only moves bishop to f1 and now
knight to f3 with check uh also uh also
playable was just knights to g to check
and allow this uh uh f3 square to be
made available for the for the pawn we
needed because if king e2 just f3 check
and that's really all there is to it uh
queen captures here and now after if the
king goes up the board we're gonna check
made the king very easily so we're gonna
have to play some like king to g3 but
then knight h4 threatening queen f3
checkmate and there really isn't a good
way to stop this you have to play queen
d5 or queen captures on b7 to guard this
but now just um a very simple queen d3
check wins the bishop here and that's it
we're up a piece we're completely
winning there's nothing white can do
about this so this was possible but
magnus goes for uh
more of a finesse move he plays knight
to f3 with check king to e2 and now of
course queen captures on f1 with check
we've reached the position from the
thumbnail uh hopefully uh king captures
on f1 and now knight captures on d2 with
a royal fork this will win back the
queen so queen e2 knight captures pawn
captures and now we get the position
that we discussed if we remove all the
pieces from the board it's gonna be a
king and pawning game where black is
just up a pawn so king g7 king to f3 now
comes king to g6 king e4 uh white uh
getting a a lot of space in with the
king here but magnus just pushes it back
with the d5 check and the pawn of course
cannot be captured if it's captured then
the white king can no longer reach in
this pawn the pawn is becoming a queen
so after d5 check you have to go back
king f3 but now just f5 now
as it is with
king and pawn end games uh the more you
trade down the more winning you will be
so h3 we have b5 now uh preventing any
c4 ideas uh and b4 now stopping a5 but
it doesn't really matter here magnus
played h5 and he was in this position on
move 36 that uh daniel nordick resigned
in the game and a very nice victory for
magnus carlsen uh for those of you who
really enjoyed when i finished the games
here there's really not all that much
for white to do white can play like b3
and then we just trade captures captures
characters captures and after we play a
king move uh that's it if you go to h5
the f pawn is too fast
you you're not going to be able to stop
it
and if f3 you of course uh allow the uh
black king to reach the f5 square and i
have king f2 g4 and that's it king g2
whatever king e4 and now these pawns are
just controlling everything here you're
just going to pick up all the pawns and
just win the game easily
so after h5 uh uh nordisk resigned and
another very nice victory for magnus
carlsen so in terms of the match they
played like 50 games 49 games to be
exact and the end result is 31 and a
half for magnus and 16 and a half for
for naraditsky uh they both started
around 3 100 bullet rating i think and
then uh near the end i think magnus was
like maybe what 31.50 and now this was
maybe on 30 or maybe 3090 something like
that now if you guys want to check out
all the games you can just you know go
on leeches and click on them or i've
seen um
john bartholomew streamed uh the entire
tournament or the entire match so you
can check it out i will put a link to it
in the description below first thing you
will see so you can check out all the
games if you guys are into that uh so
yeah uh that's the game i hope you guys
uh those were the games hope you guys
enjoyed them uh i would like to thank
jean francois bond uh matthias um uh
bolinga uh oliver nius uh the hoodie guy
and the wean machine for contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
checking up on uh everything else that's
happening in the chess world uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day